recently an article was written about
elon musk on how he's approaching the
next recession that's coming up and he
mentioned three different ps the first p
predict the second p prepared the third
p persevere let me make a prediction to
you i predict the next six 12 24 months
real estate is about to experience a
massive crash based on a ton of research
we have done to show why this is going
to be coming up in the next six to 24
months now you may say pat how you know
your prediction is right this is my
prediction you can have your own
prediction but the question will be the
following are you prepared if i'm right
and will you persevere if i'm right i
hope i'm wrong but i believe i'm right
based on the data that we have and you
have to see this for yourself so whether
you are in the real estate industry or
you're not i'm hosting a free webinar
next tuesday night the 19th at 5 30 p.m
the last webinar we did like this a
month ago it was so full we were being
bombarded by emails and text messages of
people that couldn't get in so lock in a
slot click on the link above or below
get registered put it in your calendar
and i'll see you on this free webinar
next tuesday the 19th at 5 30 pm